voilà la la la la la la c'est malin vous
pouvez être fiers de vous personne
malade
quelle honte mais comment va y arriver
ranger tout ça c'est pas possible je
suis trop petit aux dix mois casimir
qu'est-ce que ça et bien que se
passe-t-il je viens de rencontrer
monsieur du snob
il est dans une colère terrible il m'a
dit que dieu est un danger public qu'on
devrait tout laisser entrer nos jeunes
ne me parle plus d'un mode tous noirs où
je vais me mettre en colère
pourquoi es-tu en colère contre lui
parce qu'à moi sous du snob m'a demandé
de ranger tout ça en cinq minutes
il veut que je classe tous les objets
par groupe d'un objet qui vont ensemble
je comprends pas ghazi mai mais c'est
pourtant facile regarde voilà par
exemple ça il est je range avec cette
palme tous les objets qui servent à la
plongée sous marine
mais pourquoi tu obliges t-il à faire
tout faire non pas parce que je suis
malade écoute quasi mais on peut pas
obliger quelqu'un qui est malade à faire
quelque chose qui veut pas c'est
impossible
mais si monsieur du snop profitent de
maman la vie et de ma faiblesse tmi soit
ajouté
explique moi ce qui s'est réellement
passé ensuite avec les enfants eh bien
nous aideront à arranger tout ça par
groupe
c'est bon je te le promets bon alors
voilà moss ou du snob et el aroui il
terminait de ranger tous les objets
qu'ils avaient sorti de son grenier
j'arrive je lui dit poliment
bonjour monsieur du snav il me répond
bonjour mon bon casimir bien se tenir
jusque là tout se passe plutôt bien bon
bah si c'est pour dire des banalités
pareil hein c'est vraiment pas la peine
autre bien je m'en veux aller continue
un mauvais caractère
bon je continue
il me dit comment vas tu je lui réponds
pas très bien monsieur du snob
j'ai attrapé un gros rhume j'ai déjà
éternuer on se voir ce matin c'est tout
ce qu'il a le culot de me répondre à nos
os et des toits
j'ai cru qu'il y avait en orange et que
c'était le tonnerre mais ce n'est pas
tout il me dit aussi tu devrais est
éloigné parce que c'est tuer terre nuit
ici ça risque d'être une vraie
catastrophe
tu te rends compte alors au moment où
j'allais lui répondre poliment
j'ai été pris d'une irrésistible envie
d'éternuer est un atout et alors
et alors alors il est devenu odieux
odieux
pourtant je l'aide est gentiment à
ramasser tous les objets par terre j'ai
compris qu'elle aimait en éternuant tu
as fait s'envoler à travers le jardin
tous les objets que monsieur du snob
était en train de classer par groupe
ouais mais ce n'est pas tout lui aussi
était assis par terre il était furieux
que je comprenne qui peut un à chaque
fois plus éternue il se produit des
catastrophes
oui mais je ne supporte pas que l'on
prenne mes éternuements pour le tonnerre
bon casimir
j'en parlerai à monsieur snob et en
attendant avec les enfants eh bien on va
t'aider à classer tous à présent si
gentil alors venez avec moi
venez on va aider quasiment il faut se
dépêcher j'ai plus que ça n'est menée
les enfants venaient tous ça me donnait
tout cas c'est aussi en parla vous aviez
mais dès qu'on n'était pas sur la table
parce que les amis qui sont chez eux ne
verront pas les objets leur est gentil
tiens voilà vous mettez comme ça alors
voilà ce qu'il se passe
casimir tenait à l'écouté casimir veut
on va vous expliquer ce club qui était
en train de ranger soigneusement des
objets par groupe
casimir arrive il éternue et tout est
mélangé alors on va l'aider à classer
tous par groupe c'est entendu
on s'y retrouve plus bien venez avec moi
à la verrais mieux tant et si bien
gardés bien plus qu'à lire il faut
croquer ce que c'est bien l'ensemble
quoi ça ça c'est un cercle
c'est un sac à quoi ça sert il
enregistre des choses de gao non un
homme c'est sa vie ça sert à transporter
des choses des objets bien non alors
sylvie tu prends le sac tu va le mettre
dans l'herbe la voilà on le pense et si
oui on va répartir les enfants
maintenant vous cherchez dont tous les
objets qui servent à transporter des
objets ou des choses et vous les mettez
ensemble entendu ça ah oui c'est un
autre ça voilà way qui se serait encore
qu'est ce qu'ils entendent et cherchez
bien là-dedans que rien mais craint
cherchez bien voilà oui très bien tu
mets tout ça ici bon alors maintenant
attendez attendez aride
j'ai un doute mais cela ne l'a pas tout
à la fois pas tout à la fois les enfants
j'aime beaucoup ça la regarde un autre
c'est un sac ça les enfants
c'est un chapeau bora bon été à tous les
chapeaux on va les mettre ensemble de
l'or entendu oui trouver un gardien il
va trouver deux chapeaux qui adulé mais
ici les sacs la barre tous les chapeaux
ans un chapeau l'a ensuite
bon alors maintenant on cherche tous les
objets qui servent à faire de la musique
musique à isabelle alors une crécelle
way qu'est-ce qui est encore temps pour
un tambour ça sert à faire de la musique
et une flûte
tiens ça c'est pas un autre temps on
s'attend d'oursins tient cette ville en
bus qui va les mettre là ensemble voilà
on connaît du marcquois casimir
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on arrange les
objets qui servent qu'à un tueur la
préfère de la nature ouais une palette
colorée avec oui il ya avait un bateau
attend on rit là on va rien les montrer
à nos amis chez eux alors il ya donc une
palette ça qu'est ce que c'est les
enfants
la peinture qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore
mais elle veut pour la peinture d'accord
tu les pauses bon tu les pose là bas à
la casserole à ce que ça commençait
lundi coordonner tout ça un peu moins
désordre bon casimir a pour la cuisine à
sa sincère ça puisque c'est pas un
instrument les enfants tant pis ça sera
pire des régimes série casimir grasset
il pense qu'à manger
alors qu'est ce qu'il y avait quoi on
peut faire la cuisine encore une
assiette une fourchette qui à l'heure ça
s'appelle un groupe a fait ça très bien
alexandra val posé là c'est pas rien en
compliquant de laroin qu'il pose la
dordogne
tous les objets de cuisine ensemble
casimir marthouret semblait bien à quoi
ça sert ça c'est un outil ça sert à
bricoler à travailler dans la maison
alors que jeanine ttsq yad'autres l'aide
d'un tournevis et ça nous c'est une clé
bon on va le rocher tient en bas de
l'arc en ciel ne nous tombera ou pelé
outils d'accord lisent ou alors la balle
voyage très bien que rien avec nous qui
la cuisine attaque mais qu'est-ce qui
reste maintenant sur la table
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que c'est
que ça grâce à ces biens bon marché
eh bien on laisse on laisse tous
ensemble au dessus du snop de me prêter
et la demo casimir grâce aux enfants le
mal est réparé non je vous invite est
vraiment très très sympa parce que tout
seul je serais pas arrivé mais françois
oui une chose que je veux que tu fasses
je veux que tu dises absolument à
monsieur du snob 1 comme et éternuements
ne sont pas des coups de tonnerre
je te le promets casimir plus personne
désormais ne devra comparaître et
éternuements avec des orages aujourd'hui
et dont vous avez entendu tout à l'heure
le terrible orage quel coup de tonnerre
au
julie